we'll now learn an application of
combinations uh that you probably
won't find intuitive at first but the
more you think about it'll make a lot of
sense and uh hopefully it'll make you
appreciate once again the beauty of
mathematics and then you'll also know
why you know when we say uh you know n
choose k in combinations why that's also
called a binomial coefficient because we
are going to cover the binomial theorem
so before i give you the binomial
theorem let's let's understand the
motivation for for why it's even
interesting so let me let me erase that
invert colors
so if we just have to multiply i don't
know i
well let's just take different powers of
a binomial binomial is just a polynomial
with two terms right so
a plus b
well a plus b to the zero that's equal
to one right anything to the zero is
equal to one
a plus b
to the one well that equals a plus b
squared
that equals and if you don't have a lot
of practice doing this you might be
tempted to say a squared plus b squared
but you should correct yourself quickly
and slap yourself on on the wrist or the
brain or someplace
if you did that because that's a
plus b
times a plus b
and then we could use the distributive
property or if you learned it this way
in algebra 1 you could use the foil
property that equals a times a plus b
right plus b times a plus b
which is equal to a squared
plus
a b
plus b a
plus
b squared which is equal to a squared
two a b
plus b squared that should be a bit of a
review for you
and now it gets a little bit more
interesting what is let me circle that
just so we remember it that's a plus b
squared
what's a plus b to the third
a plus b to the third
and now this is starting to get
complicated this is equal to
a plus b
times a plus b
times
a plus b
or another way to view it it's a plus b
squared times a plus b right this is a
power of 3. so this was a plus b squared
so if we multiply it by a plus b we'll
we'll get a plus b to third so let's do
that let's multiply this times a plus b
so
a
plus
b
so first let's multiply everything times
b so that's
b let me do this in another color
a
squared b right that's a squared times b
now let's do 2 a b times b so plus 2 a
b
squared right 2 a b times b and then
plus b
cubed
and then we have a times a well that's a
to the a cubed right
a cubed none of these match that so i'll
put in another column
a times 2a b well that's 2
a squared b
2 a squared b
i'll put that out here
2 a squared b and then a times b squared
well that's plus
a
b squared right and now let's add up all
of the terms all we did is the
distributive property again right we
multiplied a times all of these terms
and then added that to b times all of
these terms
if we add it all up
i'll try to do it in order of let's see
let's put the
a cubed first
that's a cubed
and then
oh actually we already had this this
thing this 2a squared b i could have
written it here 2
a squared b because i had an a squared b
here so
i just rewrote the 2a squared b here so
we have a cubed plus 2a squared b plus a
squared b that's 3
a squared b
and then
two a b squared plus a b squared that's
three a b squared
and then plus b cubed
as you can see that involved a lot just
to take something to the third power so
we could you know if we had the time we
could figure out what a plus b
to the fourth power is or what a plus b
to the tenth power is but as you could
imagine this would take you all day so
wouldn't it be neat if there were
an easy way
to calculate what a binomial is to an
arbitrary power and that's where the
binomial theorem comes into play and so
in this video i'm going to
show you what the binomial theorem is i
will show you how to apply it i will
show you a trick or a technique that
will make you seem like a genius and
then in the next video i'll
hopefully give you some intuition for
why the binomial theorem actually
involves combinations why it involves
actually the binomial coefficient at all
so what is the binomial theorem let me
erase all of this
and you know you could confirm that the
binomial theorem works for you know the
ones that we've worked out up to eight
you know a plus b to the third you could
work out a plus b to the fourth if you
like to punish yourself
let's see
clear image invert color so the binomial
theorem tells us
that
a
plus
b to the nth power
is equal to and i know it's going to
look complicated at first but we'll do a
couple of examples and you'll see it's
not that intimidating it equals the sum
from k
equals 0 to n right this n is the same
thing as that n
of
each term is n choose k right we're
going to keep incrementing k up from 0
to n
of x
to the n
minus k
times
y to the k
i know that looks complicated but if we
do a couple of concrete examples i think
it should make
a reasonable amount of sense
so given oh sorry
this is
this isn't i was copying this down this
is this should be a
to the n minus k and this should be b
what i had written down before that
would be x plus y to the n but if we
have a plus b to the n
n choose k each term a to the n minus k
times b to the k
so let's let's apply this a couple of
concrete examples so we could even
switch around the variable names if we
want just to show you that they don't
have to be a's and b's they can be
anything
so what is
a
plus b
let's do one that we otherwise would
have found fairly difficult
a plus b to the fourth power
well that the binomial
theorem tells us that let's see the
first
the first term is going to be well
what's n first of all n is 4 in this
case so it equals let me fill in all the
numbers actually from k equals 0 to 4
of n of 4
choose k right because k is what we're
incrementing
a to the 4
minus k
b to the k right i just substituted the
n to the binomial theorem definition
and what does that equal
well the first term is k equals 0. so
that's 4
choose 0. so out of 4 things i'm going
to choose 0 and i'll show you in the
next video why that works
of a to the four minus k well the first
term k is zero so it's a to the fourth
b to the zero right so the b that's just
one so we can just ignore it so what's
the next term
well it's going to be four
choose one
and now k is one so four minus one is
three
a to the third
and k is one now we're in the this is
the zero term this is the first term
so b to the
first plus so as you can see each term
we go the a term the first term
whichever it is it decrements it starts
at at the power n or the fourth power
and then each term it goes down by one
and then the second term the b term it
starts at the zeroth power so it starts
at one so that's why you don't see it
there and then each term it increments
up
so then the next one so i think you see
the pattern is going to be four choose
two
a squared b squared
plus
four choose three
a
b to the third
plus
four choose four
now i'll have a to the zero so that's
just one b to the fourth
so we're done if we just figure out what
these
binomial coefficients are and that's
where they come from from the binomial
theorem but we remember how to calculate
that right in general
in general and hopefully you have the
intuition on this you shouldn't just
memorize it
n choose k from our combinatorics is
equal to n factorial
over k factorial
divided by n minus k factorial
and minus
k factorial
so in this case what's 4 choose 0 that
equals
i know it seems very
time consuming right now although it's
less time consuming than actually
multiplying it out but i'll show you a
trick in a second that will amaze you
so this is equal to 4 factorial
over 0 factorial
times
4 factorial right 4 minus 0 is 4
a to the
fourth plus four factorial
over
one factorial
times three factorial right four minus
one is three factorial
a to the third b
plus
i know this is getting a little tedious
but i think it's good to completely work
through one entire problem
plus 4 choose 2 that's 4 factorial
over 2 factorial times 2 factorial right
4 minus 2 is 2
a squared b squared
plus 4 choose 3 that's 4 factorial
over 3 factorial
and 4 minus 3 is 1 factorial 1 factorial
a
b cubed and then 4 choose 4. that's plus
4 factorial over 4 factorial times 0
factorial b to the 4th and notice this
coefficient is the same as that
coefficient this coefficient is the same
as this coefficient and then this one's
in the middle so let's evaluate them and
i'll switch colors
so zero factorial in case you don't know
it it's actually defined to be 1 which
is a little bit non-intuitive because 1
factorial is also 1 but that's just
something you should know so 4 factorial
divided by 0 factorial times 4 factorial
this is actually equal to 1. so the
first term is just a to the fourth
plus
4 factorial that's 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 divided by 3 times 2 times 1 so
that equals 4
4 a cubed b
plus
4 factorial that's 4 x 3 x 2 times 1 so
that's 24
right
over what's 2 factorial that's just 2.
so 2 times 2 is 4
so 24 divided by 4 is 6. so 6
a squared b squared
plus well four five this this term is
the same as this term right just the one
factor on the three factorial got
switched around and you might want to
think
about that for a few seconds as to why
that is it should make a little sense to
you but that is
so it's going to be 4
a
b cubed and it makes sense right because
we just this could have just been b plus
a a plus b and b plus are the same thing
so it makes sense that there's this
symmetry
right that we have four a b cubed and we
also have four a cubed b
ignore me if that if you find that
confusing if you find it enlightening
all the better
and then the last term four factorial
this this term is the same thing as this
term and we've already figured that
equals one so plus
b to the fourth so i had a little
symmetry the coefficients are one four
six four one and i'll show you know in a
future video that that these are
actually the the terms of a pascal
triangle which is another
uh well another avenue to go in
mathematics
but anyway this was an application of
the binomial theorem and i realized i've
taken 12 minutes so far so i will do
more examples in the next video see you
soon